I should comment you are dressed
absolutely respondedly tonight you've
been at an event have you uh thank you I
have I was at the palace at lunchtime uh
with the queen consort I'm a trustee of
women of the world and she is the patron
so we had a lovely uh hour in the long
Gallery with her and talking about
hopefully getting to gender equality
amazing and you've got some research out
today uh haven't you just explain what
does it show yeah so this is the first
time the British chose of Commerce have
done this research 4 000 respondents
both men and women looking at their
Career Development
um so run really interesting findings uh
two-thirds of women still say that they
have been impacted in their career
journey through Child Care
responsibilities
over 80 of people don't believe there's
enough support for more General caring
responsibilities and 50 of women are
worried about how menopause is going to
impact them so
it feels like this is an issue that
we're only really recently starting to
talk about I mean I certainly feel that
as a woman like this is something that
it's really only become on the national
conscience I mean other than the people
going through it or who have gone
through it quite recently yeah
definitely I mean having been in
business and in government it's really
only been the last I would say maximum
five years where you see people talking
about it and we see much more through
our chamber Network them talking about
it because it's what businesses want to
talk about and obviously women and men
of course
um and you know there's the whole piece
around understanding understanding how
it impacts people doesn't and everyone
of course uh training around that
supporting and then having to sort of
think about how you can work in
flexibility around helping people go who
are going through that but it's just
great that people are talking about it
so people begin to understand it's
something they need to learn about and
then child care as well is such a huge
thing I mean it should be for both
parents obviously but in reality it's
often women's whose careers are impacted
by this and that I guess that's what
your researchers has found yeah yeah it
absolutely is and what we found is
that impact is because it's very hard
for women to find affordable child care
you have to be earning a certain salary
before it's really worth you you know
going back to work so it's about
affordable child care it's about
accessible child care because it's also
quite hard to find if you can find it so
you know what we want to do is say we've
looked at all these issues you know
these aren't there aren't quick fixes we
want to have a sort of three-year
campaign where we can put together a an
equity commission we can say okay let's
bring employers together with government
with with their employment experts what
are the policies that government can put
in place what are the best practice that
that business can put in place and how
can we really move the needle and it's
interesting you said that man is one is
women did you find a bit of a gender gap
should we say on whether or not people
felt that child care and having kids had
impacted their careers it was definitely
more women who saw an impact on their
career when it came to child care the
men in fact the Gap really closed when
it came to more General caring
responsibilities which you know you
assume are sort of probably parents
elderly relatives yeah and families and
friends
um there was a much you know there were
86 percent of people saying there's not
enough support around that General
caring piece
um and you know you hear from women more
and more who probably have both Child
Care responsibilities and caring for
parents at the same time so that's a
double impact
um but you know we've got the budget
next week yeah what are you hoping to
see in it then so we are you know
there's 1.1 million open roles in the UK
50 of our businesses say they are
struggling to recruit people so you know
Chancellor we really want to look at
ways of bringing people back into the
work Force about 1.7 million people
don't work because of caring
responsibilities
86 of them are women now of course not
all of them want to work but actually
you know if you can have access to
affordable child care yeah you have that
option so what we want to see is the
chance to look at things like the
current tax-free allowance of two
thousand pounds he could raise that he
could work in other ways of using the
tax system to help couples uh with tax
you know Child Care get attacks or if
you're self-employed for example through
business expenses so we would love to
see him act on Child Care uh next week
um I'm going to ask a bit of a personal
question because your mother as well and
I know that we sort of spoken a bit
about this um off camera
do you feel that your career has been
impacted by having kids
so my kids are a little bit older now
but
um yeah I mean I was I was in a really
privileged position that by the time I
came to have children I was sort of well
paid enough that I could afford child
care and go back to work both of them
after about nine months but I definitely
saw my salary Plateau during those
probably four or five years and that was
a point at which my husband's salary
overtook mine and often there's critical
moments in your career right when you're
just getting like you said you've just
got to a certain level you about you've
got the experience and then suddenly
you're like say kind of plateauing yeah
and and actually when maybe when the
when your partner is earning more than
it generally was falls on you to take
the calls from the school when
something's Gone Gone Wrong
um I'm very lucky to have a very
supportive husband but yeah yeah it's
always a Juggle is how it is exactly
yeah I remember getting the advice that
you know if you managed to kind of stand
still in your career when you've got
four children under five then that's an
achievement in itself yeah which is not
what we want in our labor force is it
you know it's not it is great of course
for women who want to go back to work
but it's about the economy yeah it's
about that sort of wasted talent that
could be back in our Workforce that at
the moment we really really need so how
do we support those women who want to go
back back to work to be able to do what
they want to do and give back to the
economy and also good child care I guess
as well right not just any old child
care but child care that is actually
somewhere that you might feel
comfortable leaving your children and
not feel the kind of guilt that all
mothers and fathers tend to yeah feel
absolutely right a choice of types of
child care that suits as well you
probably work flexibly you know you
might work different hours diff night
shift day shift you know we need options
for child care absolutely uh really
great to have on the program thanks very
much for coming in thank you very much
woman's day you too